[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en tant qu artiste digne de ce nom
je vais vous parler de moi même donc
c'est à l'âge de 24 ans alors que je
termine ma dernière année d'études en
biochimie à l'université de liège que je
ressens un profond ennui
je ressens un vide dans ma vie et un
manque de passion et donc je me souviens
que j'étais fan de skateboard ding
adolescents d'arts martiaux de culture
urbaine donc j'hésite soit déjà des
grains un club de jeu d'échecs mais ça
manquait quand même d'activité physique
soit que je vais faire un cours de danse
un peu hip hop
donc je vais vers la danse est là dès le
premier cours j'ai eu le sentiment que
mon doigt se prenait dans un engrenage
je me suis sentie complètement téléporté
dans un autre monde je devais absolument
apprendre des suites de mouvement et par
la suite les créer moi même j'ai eu le
sentiment d'être contaminé par la plus
belle des maladies mais pour la première
fois ma raison et mon intuition est en
confrontation
donc dès ce moment là ma vie se scinde
en deux de façon complètement hermétique
d'un côté je commence à devenir
chercheur en génétique à l'université de
liège et de l'autre de façon très
boulimique
je veux faire des cours de danse danse
de tous styles et je remarque que très
vite
j'utilise tout ce que j'apprends pour
essayer de développer mon truc et ma
gestuelle donc mon esprit spontanément
efface les frontières entre les styles
de danse et sans m'en rendre compte
euh je décloisonne un an plus tard
j'intègre une école de danse et je
refuse de faire le spectacle de fin
d'année parce qu'en fait je ne suis pas
animé par l'ego du danseur d'être
absolument sur scène ce qui m'intéresse
c'est encore une fois la composition et
lors du spectacle de fin d'année
je vois une chorégraphie et je vous
promets qui me choque
littéralement pourquoi alors les
danseurs avaient les pieds fixe dans le
sol et faisait une suite de mouvements
complexes avec les bras et les mains
tous ensemble dont la structure se
répéter dans le temps et évoluer je me
souviens vraiment m accroché à mon siège
et encore une fois je me suis sentie
téléporté dans un autre monde
mais cette fois ci
c'est réel j'ai été complètement
hypnotisé j'en ai tiré une conclusion
avec des mouvements on peut hypnotiser
les gens ont peu modifié la perception
du temps et peut-être que c'est le
propre de la danse et de l'art de
pouvoir créer des accélérations des
suspensions temporel je me suis rendu
compte aussi que la contrainte rang des
créatifs faire une chorégraphie les
pieds fixe dans le sol pour moi c'était
impossible et pourtant c'était une des
expériences visuelles les plus
incroyables je suis un petit peu plus
loin ce qui m'avait hypnotisé c'était
une structure une suite de mouvements
complexes qui se répète dans le temps et
qui évolue et très bizarrement ça m'a un
tout petit peu rappelé des éléments de
science comme l'adn des molécules les
cellules une suite d'éléments complexes
qui se répètent et évolue me voilà cinq
ans plus tard à la fin de mon projet de
recherche à l'université de liège et je
décide de prendre quelques mois
sabbatiques pour choisir mon laboratoire
de recherche est rédigé une thèse
au lieu de ça je met même à sur un
logiciel de montage vidéo est là comme
pour la danse c'est complètement
compulsif
ça veut dire que cet outil
la vidéo était une extension de ma
démarche de chorégraphes jeu pouvait
filmer des mouvements et les recomposer
et je me retrouve assez vite à créer d
hybridation entre les deux allaient
traiter sur le même niveau et au lieu de
trouver un laboratoire de recherche
je crée à la belle qui s'appelle hocus
lab beaucoup plus tard je le nommerait
comme un laboratoire de mutation visuel
et chorégraphique
le temps passe et donc quelque temps
plus tard je rencontre une danseuse
contemporaine qui s'appelle milena
leclerc et qui est danseuse à charleroi
danses nous n'avons pas du tout la même
gestuelle mais une morphologie similaire
est une façon de se mouvoir apparemment
troublante parce qu'elles étaient
similaires
donc elle me dit manu on va créer un
spectacle ensemble je fais ok et donc on
recrute deux jeunes danseurs ont vent
studio
et on répète pour créer quelque chose
mais sans ambition d'être programmés ou
quoi que ce soit c'était vraiment la
création pure hélas le théâtre de liège
me contacter et me dit on voudrait bien
te programmé au festival pays de danse
je fais super nouvelle
sauf que ces deux mois après et que
milena part à macao travailler pour
franck au dragão donc je prends la
décision de filmer le spectacle à quatre
danseurs et de re projeté exactement au
même endroit
la vidéo met sur trois danseurs faut
savoir que la vidéo est l'unique source
de lumière est pour moi la vidéo devient
un dédoublement de la réalité en fait
excuser moi il fallait envoyer une vidéo
à ce moment là te ben désolé non ses
avants
c'est un numéro un
[Musique]
thomas tu sais envoyer la numéro à s'il
te plait merci
donc j'en étais arrivé à donc le théâtre
de liège décide de nous programmer c'est
un dédoublement de la réalité et j'en
tire une conclusion ça veut dire qu'on
avait décidé de développer un personnage
fantasmagorique basée sur notre sur une
caractéristique anne et lors d'une
répétition à danseurs qui ne connaît pas
mon passé viens voir le spectacle et me
dit manu c'est vraiment bizarre ou dira
savant fou dans son laboratoire
j'ai compris qu'être artiste était une
mise à nu et qu'il était impossible de
cacher quoi que ce soit et au final ce
spectacle était pour moi une mise en
scène d'un laboratoire
touba maintenant tu veux passer à la
deuxième vidéo merci voilà donc j'essaye
de diffuser ce spectacle et au lieu de
ça on propose de participer à une
biennale d'arts plastiques et je propose
un parcours photographique pourquoi
parce que j'ai toujours voulu
cristallisé figé mouvement comme
regarder de la danse vous n'en garder
qu'un souvenir et c'est éphémère et donc
j'ai utilisé une technique relativement
simple c'est de la photographie avec des
longues pauses de l'obscurité et des
danseurs qui danse avec des lampes de
poche
on obtient ainsi très facilement comme
jeudi leur signature chorégraphique
lumineuse c'est de la calligraphie
ensuite je prends ces photos et créent
des symétries les multiplie sous forme
de spyro graff que des effets de miroir
parce que ce qu'il m'intéresse c'est de
créer des choses relativement abstraite
de façon intuitive pour que le public et
les gens qui viennent le voir puisse se
raconter une histoire et donc pour moi
le but est de trouver un sens et de
raconte de trouver une narration mais a
posteriori et très bizarrement dans
certaines compositions je retrouvais des
genres de braid adn des genres de
cellules en suspension et des genres de
molécules
vous vous souvenez de milena thomas tu
peux envoyer la 300e play souvenez de
milena elles reviennent macao et on
décide de faire un nouveau spectacle
bien sûr comme vous savez la contrainte
rock créatif et on n'a pas d'argent donc
je veux un éléments scénographiques qui
a un impact visuel ornans et donc je
décide d'accrocher des feuilles de
papier sur des fils de nylon et ça crée
un nuage de papier aussi sable ça
devient un écran des composés utilisés
pour projeter de la vidéo mais avec
lequel le danseur peut entrer en
relation
ça ne coûte pas grand chose et c'est
adaptable à souhait
la conclusion de ce projet je me rends
compte qu'il n'ya aucune cassure d'un
projet à l'autre
pour moi c'est un laboratoire perpétuel
et parfois des projets si cristallise je
trouve une nouvelle obsession le papier
je pense que j'ai passé peut-être
beaucoup trop de temps sur les bords
d'université à prendre des notes ou
alors plus sérieusement en plus de l'art
du mouvement de la lumière de la vidéo
je voulais mettre ma main sur une notion
d'architecturé de volume pour pouvoir
maîtriser tous les éléments d'un
spectacle tel que je le concevait après
ses nombreux projets je reçois une
commande du musée de la vie wallonne
deux ans de suite
c'est un spectacle tout public ça sert à
mettre en valeur leur lieu et je peux
condensée dans ce projet là j'oublie à
chaque fois thomas tu peux envoyer
l'autre vidéo s'il te plait merci
et donc je peux condensé tout ce que
j'ai appris sur les projets précédents
dans ce spectacle là tout public les
organisateurs sont enchantés et l'équipe
technique et artistique également après
ces deux spectacles
je prends la décision de tout arrêter
parce que j'ai vraiment le sentiment que
je commence à me disperser et que
quelque chose dans mon processus
commence vraiment à se défoncer et que
enfin il serait temps que je prenne au
sérieux mon premier amour qui est
l'amour du mouvement et d'enfin trouver
ma signature chorégraphique comme je dis
c'est trouver l'essence de l'art donc là
il ya une cassure et donc je rentre dans
un travail minimaliste sur le mouvement
cette décision tombe parfaitement car
quelques mois avant sa danseurs de
breakdance super connu en belgique et
sur la scène internationale
benoît nieto durable bboy tuque
m'adresse un message manu je veux
m'ouvrir à la créativité je veux
travailler avec toi je vous cache pas
que mon ego était flatté sur ce projet
là un ami à lui que je connaissais fabio
du même groupe nous rejoint et eau
décident de monter un laboratoire
chorégraphique qui donnera lieu à un
spectacle qui se nomme vie jeunes
passent ou et thomas tu peux envoyer
d'autres vidéos
merci
magnifique c'était la première fois que
j'étais confronté à des danseurs dont je
ne maîtrisais pas lâcher situe l île et
du breakdance et eux ne comprenait pas
la mienne non plus je me suis rendu
compte à ce moment là que mon job et ma
compétence n'était pas de chorégraphier
des spectacles mais que finalement
c'était de chercher l'identité
chorégraphique chez le danseur était de
trouver une identité particulière que au
final le spectacle n'était qu'un
prétexte
ce que je voulais c'était créer des
genres de mutants chorégraphie je les ai
appelés les x men de la danse mais ne
démarche était vraiment ça alors comment
est-ce que j'ai procédé très brièvement
j'ai pris des mouvements de ma signature
que je leur ai donné comme contrainte
mais dans mon esprit c'est comme si je
leur apportais des mutations dans leurs
danses j'ai utilisé également des
contrats d' basique et simple qui était
adaptée à leur danse par exemple benoît
style extrêmement puissant et animale je
lui donnais une boîte et des lignes pour
qu'il puisse jouer avec quelques mois et
un jour fabio le voir répéter lui dit on
dirait le théorème de pythagore benoît
avait trouvé son personnage
fantasmagorique y était pythagore
je vais clôturer par un tout dernier
projet thomas tu peux rien dire des
vidéos le tout dernier projet c'est très
simple il s'appelle sic red state j'ai
fait ça va j'ai pris le projet précédent
wiegele pathway qui était que
chorégraphique et gelait transposé en
version numérique
j'ai réintégré la vidéo projection
on a fait la motion capture de la
capture de mouvements avec l'aide de
l'université de monde
et alors j'ai rajouté une contrainte
supplémentaire j'ai mis du papier au sol
ils m'ont détester mais pour moi c'était
un élément pour muter et faire évoluer
leur signature chorégraphique encore
plus loin ça leur permettait d'avoir un
touché et un équilibre qui ne l'avait
pas avant j'ai trouvé que ça a mené de
poésie aussi un petit peu différent
j'ai avant d'entonner j'ai eu
l'impression que j'étais un peu comme
monsieur miyagi qui dit à daniel san de
faire tout le temps la même chose très
très contraignante mais qu'après devient
super combattant donc en fin d'étape
dans cette démarche pour conclure sur le
sujet d'aujourd'hui en passant de la
science à l'art j'ai appris plusieurs
choses premièrement je n'ai jamais su
définir rochus lab une compagnie danse
un portfolio en laboratoire d'arts
visuels et au final je me suis dit ben
c'est un organisme vivant visuel et
chorégraphies ou peut-être une part de
mon inconscient je suis revenu aussi on
va de m'interroger ce qui se passait
entre l'art et la science est
initialement l'art et la science font
partie d'une même chose je vais pas
développer mais je vous citais léonard
de vinci des peintures rupestres et les
pyramides larchitecture les symboles
maya
j'ai aussi compris effet c'est inverser
les choses
j'ai d'abord écouté mon instinct et mon
intuition et j'ai mis ma raison et ma
faculté d'analysé au service de cette
intuition là et pour terminer je me suis
rendu compte qu'en tant que créatif si
je voulais comprendre mon présent est
anticipé mon futur je devais me plonger
dans mon passé avec sincérité et
profondeur car tout était lié
merci pour votre attention sur ce je
rejoins mon portail temporel si il
fonctionne et je saluerai ma fille qui
est dans l'audience au revoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]